hide your kids hide your wife but
especially
hide your kids because the biden
administration is planning to come to
your door
to get you jabbed with an experimental
drug
all in the name of fighting a virus that
poses
at most an infinitesimally small risk
to your kids white house press secretary
jen saki outlined the plan
yesterday rosenwald outlined five areas
his team is focused on to get more
americans vaccinated
one targeted community by community
door-to-door outreach
to get remaining americans vaccinated by
ensuring they have the information they
need
on how both safe and accessible the
vaccine is
yes the vaccine so wonderful for the
virus so dangerous
that government thugs need to go door to
door to get you to take it
but while the jab happy public health
police ought to be taken down a few
notches
in other areas the government could
actually use a heavier hand
particularly as crime spikes around the
country and
in the words of democrat senator bob
casey our democracy
reaches the point of no return i'm
michael knowles it's the michael knoll
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from jurgen
kleln who says this is in response to
matthew mcconaughey
i take it america is not heading into
puberty
it's heading and sliding into dementia
i suppose that is the the question that
is the most important question we're
dealing with now
is this a growing pain on the road to
great
national glory are we are we perhaps
sadly at the end of the roman republic
but we still have some of the glory days
of the empire before us
or is this it or the barbarians at the
gates
and are we headed into endless decline
that's the question i guess the answer
is going to be a little bit up to us
you know when you want to tune out all
the noise all the craziness
when you just want to listen to
something really really profound
you got to check out ray cons this
summer you're lounging at the pool
you're at the beach you want to listen
to your favorite
audiobook perhaps maybe you want to
listen to
your favorite podcast perhaps so maybe
you want to listen to some music
a pair of raycon wireless earbuds in
your ears can make
all the difference no matter what you
are listening to you will get crisp
powerful beats at half the price of
other premium audio
brands okay i am going to put this as
diplomatically as i can raycons it's
just a superior product to the other
stuff on the market and it's much less
expensive but it is a better product
okay raikons look great they feel even
better they come in a range of cool
colors they've got customizable gel tips
included for a comfortable in-ear
fit they are built to go wherever you go
with quick and seamless bluetooth
pairing and a compact
charging case right now raycon is
offering 15
off all their products to our listeners
here's what you've got to do to get it
go to buy raycon dot com slash
knowles wlas there you will get 15
percent off your entire rake on order
such a good deal you're going to want to
grab a pair and a spare
15 off at byraycon.com knowles by
raycon.com
knowles they're going to go door to door
by the way only in targeted communities
so i i hope you're not in one of those
targeted communities they're going to go
door-to-door
to convince you to get this vaccine
because you know it's so great
it's so great that no one wants it and
because the virus is so dangerous that
no one cares or is worried about this
other than some neurotics in new york
and los angeles
i have said i want to be very clear
about my views
on on the vaccine i think you know my
views on these people going door-to-door
i have said from the very beginning the
vaccine
is about prudence i actually don't think
that the vaccine is going to kill
everyone or turn people into a 5g
cell tower though perhaps that would be
perfectly fine because my cell service
is not that great particularly
in my new town however while i don't
i'm not saying it's going to kill you
and it's going to turn you into you're
going to get demagnetized and i'm not
saying that
also this is an experimental drug
that is very very new when people tell
you there are no long-term side effects
they have no idea what they're talking
about because there's no long term
because they just invented this thing
for a virus that didn't exist a year and
a half ago
so don't let them tell you that it's
perf a hundred percent perfectly safe
no problems whatsoever i'm not saying
there's no circumstance in which you
should get the vaccine i'm not saying
it's obvious that you should get the
vaccine
i i think we we have just completely
lost sight of the
conservative virtue in this country
which is prudence maybe you make a risk
assessment
maybe you weigh out different factors
and you think well maybe okay
this that or the other thing you
definitely don't need government thugs
showing up at your door
with a needle and by the way when they
do that when you hear them come and
knock and hey
get this perfectly 100 safe thing that
it's not even a question whether or not
you should get it
it's going to probably make reasonable
people less likely to get it
moreover healthy young people
i've got to phrase my words carefully so
we're not taken off of youtube
it seems very strange to me that healthy
young people would be so afraid of this
virus
that just has not really had terribly
negative effects on young people and was
not really threatened their lives in any
great numbers that they would get this
experimental drug it's very strange
that they would have a medical reason to
get this experimental drug
there might be other reasons that they
have to i've plenty of people have
written in they've said look i'm not
allowed back at school unless i get the
drug so i'm taking a risk calculation
i'm going to take it and i hope
i'll hope for the best okay i get that
or people at work or whatever i
yeah i get that but don't don't tell me
to deny reality don't tell me that in
order for us to move
past this [ __ ] the worst epidemic
pandemic in history we all need to we
need to inoculate 12 year olds we
we don't we don't i know i'm sorry i
know i'm contradicting
some of the genius public health people
by the way i'm not contradicting others
many scientists are saying there's no
reason to inoculate these children
and and every day we're getting more and
more stories about this
a 13 year old boy in michigan
died suddenly in his sleep two days
after receiving
the mrna vaccine the pfizer vaccine
the cdc is investigating this by the way
this is not just some kooky thing on the
corners of the internet that isn't true
a 13 year old michigan boy
jacob kleineck got his second dose
on june 13th days after graduating from
the eighth grade
he then had the typical symptoms which
included fever and general fatigue
then he complained of a stomach ache two
days later went to bed never woke up
now the preliminary autopsy according to
the
detroit free press suggests that jacob's
heart was enlarged when he died and
there was fluid around his heart this is
the side effect
that even the public health authorities
are admitting goes along with these mrna
vaccines
not saying it goes it happens in huge
numbers we don't know but it has there
have been
many documented cases of this happening
not in old people by the way
any young people in young people who
if they were making a risk calculation
probably
probably didn't need to get the vaccine
and this poor 13 year old boy it's not
as though he's the one making the
decision his parents are making the
decision for him
feel terrible for the whole family
because the parents are just going on
the best medical advice
of the genius experts
and now it's very it's very difficult to
look at the situation
and conclude that oh this was just a
coincidence this had nothing to do with
the vaccine
yeah the boy got the vaccine that he
really didn't need if you're just
looking at the statistical chance of him
dying of coronavirus it's
infinitesimally small
so he gets this experimental vaccine and
then he suffers the symptoms that are
associated with this vaccine
in young men and then he dies
i i can't believe that's a coincidence
that seems very difficult i think that
the conspiracy theory
is that that is a coincidence the cdc
admits
there's a likely association between the
pfizer and modern
mrna vaccines and this these cases of
heart inflammation
and younger people terribly terribly sad
story
now they want to go door to door and and
get you jabbed
why why what's that about messaging is a
little bit off here
there's a professor medical professor at
nyu
who acknowledges the messaging forget
the vaccines themselves people can make
their own risk calculation and use their
own prudential judgment
the messaging on the vaccine and the
lockdowns more broadly
has been completely bungled from the top
when everything messaging changes people
get afraid and they don't know who they
can trust and there's inconsistency
and i go with the cdc with this one not
on this flip-flop by dr
fauci i think if you've been vaccinated
you're protected
over 95 of the time and even if you got
a case it would be
really really mild so the idea of
reinstituting masks
in states that don't have as high a
vaccination rate let me give you an idea
what the actual numbers are and you'll
understand what i'm saying
in in in mississippi there's been less
than 200 new cases
a day over the past week with only three
deaths over the entire week in wyoming
less than
80 new cases a day with one death over
the entire week so if you're in wyoming
or mississippi
which don't have the kind of vaccine
compliance i want or dr faucio wants
what's the chances that you're going to
bang into this virus if you're fully
vaccinated
almost zero so it sends the wrong
message and it gets in the way of a
doctor like me
trying to convince my patients to get
the vaccine
all good points it's true the flip flops
from fouchy
and even some of the turnarounds at the
cdc and the other public health agencies
they have undermined the credibility of
doctors and scientists
and that's too bad you know and isn't
that too bad i think i'm not i'm not
accusing dr siegel of doing this but i
think a lot of people
have been saying it's just it's just
crazy there unfortunately fauci has
undermined our credibility but you need
to believe us no he did he that's the
thing about undermining credibility is
it happened
it when and when it happens then you
don't have credibility
and that's why people are going to be
looking to other sources for information
about the vaccines and the lockdowns and
the virus and the origins and the whole
thing
and they're not crazy for that and
they're not anti-scientific and they're
not anti-intellectual they're smart
they're smart when someone lies to you
repeatedly
and when someone deceives you and when
someone downplays risks and when someone
does
this that and the other thing you're
going to you're going to turn
elsewhere for your information and
you're totally totally justified
in doing that when things get kind of
crazy you know what you know what is a
great way to hedge your investments
physical gold and yet you might say
michael i just don't have
all that money in the couch cushions
right now well what if i told you you
can start investing in physical gold
without coming out of pocket all at once
you can do it for as low as 30
a month you lie michael don't call me a
liar how dare you i'm not lying at all
i'm
telling you that acre has this ingenious
new product
where you in invest every month you send
in 30
when your gold stash reaches the price
of their gold bars
they will discreetly ship acre gold to
your house they've also got a 100
a month subscription to a 5 gram gold
bar and they'll keep you updated every
month and then they'll send you your
physical gold i have really enjoyed
investing in physical precious metals
especially
acre gold i really enjoy investing in
that especially now when everyone's all
worried about inflation as well they
should be
head on over to get anchor gold dot com
slash knowles started investing in
physical gold today make sure you go to
this url
because acre is giving away a gold bar
to qualify for the giveaway tweet or
post why you should be the recipient
and mention at get underscore acre
that's get acre goal dot com knowles and
thank you aker gold for supporting the
show
speaking of drugs you're gonna have the
biden administration coming around
trying to jab you with an experimental
drug
there are other drugs out there not just
those coveted vaccines there are lots of
other drugs out there
they're trying to legalize a lot of
drugs throughout the country a lot of
conservatives have gone along with this
even or at least libertarians but some
conservatives too oh who cares legalize
pot
legalize even harder drugs than that
well we got a real blast from the past
this week
where a u.s olympian shikari richardson
will not be permitted to run in the
olympic 100 meter race
because she has a one month ban for
testing positive
for smoking the old sin spinach you know
those jazz cigarettes that peruvian
parsley you catch what i'm putting out
there
i'm talking about the haitian oregano
you know what i mean marijuana
so she came out and you know tested
positive for this and
a lot of people are saying this is
outrageous some people are saying it's
racist or whatever you know
because everything bad is racist these
days some people are saying it's unfair
it's
very sad for her it's very sad that she
will not get to run
in this cool race that she's been
training her whole life for because she
wanted to smoke a doobie
and that's unfortunate
she knew the risks okay when she decided
to uh spark up the gange
she she knew the risks i guess she
thought it wouldn't be enforced
because a lot of our rules are not
enforced anymore which is the flip side
of this
but even joe biden even joe biden
right he licks his finger in the morning
figures out which way the winds are
blowing
he's been blowing very progressively so
he's been moving to the left
he was asked about this and he said you
know what the rules are the rules
sir do you think the ban is fair do you
think her ban is fair for marijuana
it's the rules or the rules and
everybody knows that the rules we're
going in
whether they should remain that that
should remain a little bit different
issue
rosa rosa and i was really proud of the
way she responded
and so okay thank you i love
the first part of this response at the
end you hear biden did this clinton
thing this bill clinton thing where he
tried to get both sides of the issue he
goes
rules are the rules the rules are the
rules okay but i was really proud of how
she responded what do you mean she
responded she was extremely angry and
thinks it's unjust
i was really so he's trying to get both
sides of it but i love that first line
very conservative this is probably my
favorite thing joe biden's ever said
rules are the rules sorry guys smoke a
little bit of the devil's lettuce that's
what's going to happen to you
this shows you the two sides of it
you know in politics little manifestos
little ideologies that can fit on the
back of a napkin
are really never true i just oh gosh i
just finished reading
ein rand's atlas shrugged we're i'll be
talking about that in the coming weeks
but i've been putting off reading it for
for 10 15 years at this point and it's
just
terrible and it's terrible in part
because the ideology is so
thin it's so simple it's so clear
shallows are clear okay
so i i want to make sure that well
obviously we want to resist the tyranny
of biden's thugs going door to door
jabbing people with an experimental drug
that in many cases is not going to
improve their health outlooks
at the same time we need to recognize
that the government could use a heavier
hand in other places the government has
become very permissive
those those uh rioters the blm riders
they all
not all of them but most of them got off
the hook especially in new york they
just got completely off the hook
that's where we need more big government
that's where we need a heavier hand
of government the people who stormed the
capital
and stole nancy pelosi's lectern in
january
those guys are gonna rot in prison right
so i suspect what shikari
richardson was thinking is okay there's
just uneven enforcement of this rule i'm
gonna take my chance
no the you you need to enforce the rules
if you're going to have a society of law
not
of men now biden so biden good job on
this i actually really like that i never
say anything nice about biden but i
liked his answer there
otherwise biden is not instilling a ton
of trust joe biden was just asking
questions about
russia and he couldn't he couldn't give
a straight answer because he doesn't
know what's going on because
his brain is soup at this point so he
pulled out some notes
to uh to read what they told him with
the most recent hack
by the russians would you say that this
this means
we're not sure it's the russians i got a
brief and uh
uh i'll be in better shape to talk to
you about it
i'll tell you what they sent me the idea
first of all we're not sure
who it is for certain number one and
what i did i directed the full resources
of the government to
assist in a response one question
who is they hear the president of the
united states
uh you're asking me about russia hold on
let me find out that's my shopping list
let me uh
okay here here's what they sent me who
is day you've got the
the conspiracy theorists are probably
going pretty wild right now
because joe biden is admitting that he's
not he's not running the country
himself that he's taking orders from
some mysterious
them obviously he can't keep up with
this this reminds
me of those sort of late stage soviet
dictators
you know the ones at the end where they
just they would live for like five
minutes and they were just so
out of it and it was just so broke until
you got to to gorbachev and they were
just it was so
sad and they were just completely
collapsing that's that's what biden is
doing and he's allowing
them to run the country and especially
to run foreign policy and i suspect by
them he means
the establishment he means the state
department he means the people who have
been running foreign policy
for many decades now and whenever a
president goes in and tries to shake
things up
the the blob the liberal establishment
the permanent government just kind of
impedes them from doing that and that's
what's happening here
more lucid members of the biden
administration are somehow incredibly
even worse than he is i'm thinking of
attorney general
merrick garland who just
last week wrote that he will
block federal execution so federal
executions had been stopped
obama did not engage in federal
executions then trump comes in he kicks
off federal executions again
so people who have been convicted who
have been sentenced to death
they just were languishing on death row
trump said now we're going to start
killing him again i mean these are the
most heinous crimes you can possibly
imagine
and then the attorney general merrick
garland under biden comes in and says no
we're not going to do that anymore
and that's not surprising the libs don't
want
rapists and serial killers and child
rapist killers to be punished
and republicans tend to want to punish
them so okay
we can expect that what's interesting
here is the reasoning
that merrick garland gave in in
garland's memo to the doj
he said that the application of the
death penalty had exhibited
arbitrariness in its application again
that's a
kind of weak sauce you normal
boilerplate stuff and
disparate impact on people of color
that's the problem is
too many of the people who are
committing these capital offenses
who are then sentenced to death are are
black people
in other words not enough people who are
committing capital offenses and being
sentenced to death
are white people so so the
the argument is not totally about
justice here it's not even largely about
you it's not about
the immorality of the death penalty and
how it's intrinsically evil or unjust
because it's not because it's impossible
to make that argument
instead the argument is not enough white
people are frying
and so because not enough white people
are frying
we have got to suspend the death penalty
entirely
kind of a perverse logic to that don't
you think
that i mean this is how racial politics
makes people
kooky is when you just when you come to
the conclusion
that there can be no group differences
in outcome in behavior in in any sort of
aspect of life based on
in this case race but the other factors
would be considered as well
that that any any change whatsoever any
difference whatsoever has to be the
result
of some systemic injustice why then
you've got to
change the system and you're seeing this
now in oregon this is probably the most
preposterous version of this
oregon is considering whether or not to
drop the bar exam
as a requirement for lawyers so the bar
exam is the
you go to law school you take your test
then you take the bar and the bar is
what decides whether or not you get to
be a lawyer
well there's a problem according to a
task force
of the oregon board of bar examiners
and the the problem is this that
not enough non-white people are passing
that white people are passing at
relatively high rates i think it's in
the 80s
and then hispanics it's in the 70s
percent and then for black people it's
in the 60s
and because of that we need to get rid
of the bar exam
not we need to figure out how to make
hispanic and black people do better on
the bar
no no that can't it can't possibly be
that we're going to
bring people up and recognize the
standard of excellence
and recognize that there is an objective
standard to which we've all got to
uh adhere no
we've got to bring everybody down we've
got to now have a
legal system in which lawyers don't need
even the basic competency exam
of the bar this this is harrison
bergeron i mean this is that i mentioned
this story by kurt vonnegut a while ago
that in this future that's gone mad with
equity and egalitarianism and
and all these modern ideologies
you're going to have a society of people
who have intentionally
been handicapped so no one can excel
anyone else that is
this is an area where i think we need a
heavier hand for government
okay we need the government to actually
or in this case i suppose even the
legal institutions associated with the
government you need
a bar exam you need a requirement for a
bar exam and you can't give people bonus
points on their bar just because their
skin is a little darker than you
than you otherwise would give them
credit for you know if you're you you
take out a swatch and you say okay
well because you get an extra 300 points
but no that's not
that is not going to lead to a
flourishing society it's not good for
the people that you think that you're
helping
it's not good for the people that you
think that you're hurting obviously
and it's not good for society to have a
bunch of incompetent lawyers
reminds me of that a lot was that line
from from henry vi i think
it from shakespeare is let's kill all
the lawyers one of the most one of the
most famous lines from the bard you know
speaking of lawyers ben shapiro today is
going to be talking about how to create
an emergency
to grab power specifically talking about
what's going on in new york with andrew
quovid's
gun grabbing schemes so make sure you go
check
that out also you know the freedom that
we experience here in america
it is at least historically unparalleled
many americans
don't realize just how much of that
freedom was paid for in blood by heroes
that have faded into history
without the recognition they deserve
which is why in honor of
the week of america's independence the
daily wire is celebrating these men
with our newest podcast america's
forgotten heroes which boasts
seven episodes detailing the lives of
seven legendary men who risked it all
for america subscribe now
to america's forgotten heroes on apple
podcast spotify or anywhere you might
listen
because the last episode is out today
wednesday july 7th for a total of seven
episodes
because too many heroes never receive
the recognition they deserve and sharing
their stories with you on this
independence day holiday is our small
tribute to their heroism
if you like what you hear leave a 5 star
review help share these incredible
stories
thank you for listening thank you to the
heroes that made such a tremendous
podcast
possible we'll be right back with a lot
more
welcome back to the show everyone
talking about critical race theory
recently the left defending critical
race theory then denying the critical
race theory exists
now back to defending critical race
theory
ben carson has weighed in on this issue
ben carson offers i think a very solid
definition what everyone's asked what is
it define critical rate
i think it gives a very solid definition
and why it's so terrible
for our society it's an attempt to
use race as a mechanism
for redefining our society redefining
what it was based on and how it impacts
everybody
and it wants our people to believe that
your race
is the most critical determinant of who
you are
and what happens to you in our society
in other words
it's a bunch of garbage i love that last
part
in other words it's a bunch of garbage
this is true what he's describing is
true
very often in the debate over crt
especially with these parents who are
showing up to school boards
you're hearing the left preen and and
boast and say oh these unwashed idiots
they don't know what they're talking
about they can't even define critical
race theory
ben carson is more intelligent
and better educated than
all of those people combined right ben
whatever you want to say about ben
carson
you can't say the guy is a dummy i don't
know if you remember in 2016 when he was
running for president
and they went around all the republican
candidates they said what's the thing
you're proudest of and you know
senator so-and-so says i'm proudest of
having passed this bill
and governor so-and-so says i'm proudest
of having passed this executive order
and then it gets to ben carson goes i'm
proudest of uh i don't know
separating conjoined twins at the head
for the first time that was pretty cool
you know like oh wow you're in a
completely different category
and so one thing that ben carson does
very well is he takes very complex ideas
and he he boils them down so what he's
saying is
critical race theory it's not that it's
a serious academic field it's not
it's an analytical framework and really
an
an
ideological tool to redefine
our society it is intended to do
what the 6019 project says it wants to
do reframe american history
to put slavery at the center of it to
put race at the center of it
to reframe your sense of yourself to
make you believe that race is
the most important aspect of your
identity
nobody denies that race has something to
do with your identity
the fact that i am of italian
abstraction
says something to do with the way that i
speak with my hands it has something to
do with the way that i eat i eat a lot
of pasta it says something to do
with the way that i think about culture
the way that i think about history
but it's not at the top
there are more important things
traditionally in america we have
believed that our unity as
americans donald trump says we all bleed
the same blood of patriots
that is more important we believe
traditionally in america that our
religion is more important i certainly
do
we believe that our our bonds of
community at the local level
more important we believe that our civic
associations
often more important and what critical
race theory
says is no that's all bunk race is the
determining factor
and so recognize that america is just
permanently stuck in this
this racial problem and and it attempts
to redefine the country
absolutely right now what this leads to
is a lot of low expectations for black
people you heard i think this gerson
described the soft bigotry of low
expectations
that when you just don't believe that
black people can do anything
that is a sort of bigotry because you're
even even though very often it's white
liberals who have this view
it they'll they are expressing a kind of
bigotry because they they
are viewing black people as less than
human the the whole idea of
intersectionality the the radical racial
ideologies on the left now
are bigoted because they the only people
that they view as fully human are white
men
according to the left's radicalism only
white men possess
intellect and will we're the only people
that have any moral agency
and every other person on planet earth
is merely a victim of our intellect and
our will they're passive characters
in a game that is only defined by
white men right according according to
this view so that is a kind of
bigotry and we are seeing this playing
out right now in the streets of san
francisco there is a video that went
viral after many many reports
of walgreens for instance closing their
doors because
people disproportionately black are
going in and
stealing stuff so they've closed a bunch
of of walgreens
now at a neiman marcus in san francisco
there's a video that's gone viral
of people again i think exclusively
black
but maybe mixed but i think it's i think
black
just go just running and you know
they've got most have hoodies on or
covering their faces with the masks that
fouchy said that guy might have been
white i'm not sure
uh going out and stealing a bunch of
stuff
the reason i focus on the race here is
if that had been a group of white people
of course this would be the crime of the
century and they'd all be rotting in
federal prison it'd somehow be a hate
crime or something but because they're
black the liberal establishment says
well they can't help it they they just
can't help themselves
what you're telling me you're telling me
you're supposed to have a department
store
in a place with black people and they're
not going to steal all the stuff come on
that's crazy
that this is this is the kind of low
expectation
that the liberal establishment has of
black people it's why they want to get
rid of the bar
exam that's why they want to lower
standards it's why they want to
reduce criminal penalties for people
on the basis of their race in and
in various areas this is bad stuff
no one will benefit the neiman marcus
might have to close the walgreens
already have closed
the the property values in the
neighborhood are going to go
to nothing the crime is going to surge
it that is a crime in and of itself
and then when crimes like that flourish
more violent crimes take place
right now chicago is like downtown
fallujah
right now chicago is looking like a war
zone
over the fourth of july weekend nearly
100 people were shot in chicago 100
people
think about that one picture one person
then 10 people and multiply that by 10.
i know it's hard for people to to
picture numbers that's how many people
took a bullet over the weekend just for
being in chicago
17 of them were shot fatally almost one
in five
dead over just a fourth of july weekend
because the democrats who run chicago
can't get the city together
abc 7 reported that 98 people were shot
in the time frame of friday at 6 pm
to 11 59 p.m on monday 17 of them
succumbing to their wounds
the chicago sun times lists the fatality
numbers higher they listed at 19.
abc7 uh points out that
that number is up pretty significantly
because
in 2020 on the fourth of july weekend
only 87 people were shot
only 87 shot back in those halcyon days
of 2020 but now it's even higher than
that
and this follows last thursday
a day on which 32 people were shot
including a one-month-old girl who was
shot
in the head worse than a third world
country
worse than a third world country because
of what because of the evil republicans
that haven't governed chicago since the
bronze age
what because of the white supremacy
because it's mega country is that i
don't think so
don't think there's a whole lot of white
supremacy in chicago don't think there's
a whole lot of mega country don't think
it's run by republicans
but that that is the excuse that is
given that is always the excuse that is
given
and no one really seems to care everyone
lets that machine
corrupt city of chicago get off the hook
constantly chicago alderman one of the
one of the few republicans in that city
anthony napolitano good italian boy good
good republican italian boy
he came out and he said the place is
resembling
a war zone chicago and the state of
illinois have the strictest gun laws
uh our it's a statistical fact that the
bulk of our guns or illegal guns come
from our border
states and not a single one of our
border stakes or any of them combined
have anywhere near 5 800 people shot in
the last 17 months
right what what politics won't tell you
is we have a human problem we have a
people problem right here there's
little accountability politicians won't
blame families for raising their kids
the gangs are raising their kids right
now we have
over 17 or 117 000 gang members
that's your problem yeah that is your
absolute problem
so chicago's mayor lori lightfoot like
past mayors of chicago
is trying to blame guns from other
states
for the shootings it's the illegal guns
um
indiana seems fine to me generally
speaking indiana doesn't look like a war
zone i don't know the border
i don't think that's really the issue i
think the issue is chicago and the crime
that is permitted to fester there
meanwhile while this is going on we are
being told by the left that we need to
defund the police we're being told that
we need to abolish prisons
we're being told that we need criminal
justice reform which is letting
criminals off the hook that's what we
need right
because we have an over-incarceration
problem looks to me like we have an
under-incarceration problem looks to me
like when 100 people are getting shot in
chicago over the weekend
17 of them being killed one month old
babies being shot in the head
sounds to me like we don't have nearly
enough of these criminals in prison
and i really really hope that
republicans stop
buying into this bogus left-wing premise
that we're not
throwing enough criminals in the clink
because or rather the
bogus loving promise that we have too
many criminals in the clink
we we need to put more criminals in jail
this is one of
unfortunately this is one of the most
frustrating things from the trump
administration
is he was convinced to put a lot of
political capital into letting criminals
out of jail
because that that's why he was elected
right no it wasn't
it wasn't he this obviously was a move
from the more liberal
wing of the gop and the more liberal
wing
of people around former president trump
let's not make that
that mistake again i know that uh you
know look trump did a lot of terrific
things
so i don't knock him too much for the
first step act but but
this is the reality of it this is the
reality of crime in america
and the only argument
that is even remotely persuasive i've
heard for
letting criminals out of prison is this
argument that well you know
a lot of these people disproportionately
these people who are in prison are black
okay that's too bad that's a that's a
problem you got to try to fix that
problem you're not going to fix that
problem by letting criminals out of jail
okay
that's not you're not make me an
argument from justice
make me don't make me an argument from
the outcome because you don't like the
racial makeup of the prisons
make me an argument from justice why
should we be letting
criminal at a time of a crime surge why
should we be letting criminals out of
jail doesn't
make a lot of sense to me
i think what a lot of this comes from
is that the left benefits from this
chaos
i think the left bent never never let a
crisis go to waste is a phrase that
crops up a lot in democrat politics the
chaos
benefits the left because it justifies
power grabs
it justifies more arbitrary enforcement
of rules
whenever there is a crisis it justifies
spending more money taking more power
you just saw it last year if you don't
if you don't believe that after last
year i don't know what to tell you
well yes we're preventing you from going
to church and yes we're shutting down
your business
but not that other business and we're
shutting down your church but not that
marijuana dispensary
and we're doing this and we're doing
that but it's a crisis don't ask
questions
well yes we're going door to door to jab
you with this thing that's an
experimental drug
but you know hey but it's a crisis you
know is it
is it take a step back take a breath
take a step back
lots of bad things going on very often
there are simple solutions there i guess
it looks as though there's a crisis in
chicago because everyone's shooting
everybody
throw them in prison beef up the police
make the police much more forceful and
aggressive
don't i don't think the problem in
chicago right now is police brutality
okay folks they need to be
more forceful throw the criminals
in prison all of a sudden your crisis
goes away
but the democrats don't want to do that
i think they are interested right now
in just wielding this arbitrary
vindictive force and this is not just my
own psychobabble
it's not because i'm biased and i you
know i don't
understand what the other side is
thinking actually it's quite the
opposite
according to a study out of uc santa
barbara new study out of uc santa
barbara
just revealed and take these surveys
with a grain of salt but
this this is an interesting point that a
lot of us i think could intuit
and know anecdotally woke democrats
dehumanized conservatives more than
conservatives dehumanized woke democrats
during the 2020 election
largely because progressives are more
misinformed
about their rivals view of them this is
according to a study
by four researchers who did not expect
to find this
at the university of california at santa
barbara
democrats expressed more dehumanization
and anti-democratic spite
toward republicans than vice versa this
appears to clash with research
suggesting that liberals are more open
tolerant and less biased toward
out-group members according to the study
and by the way the most liberal
democrats
expressed the greatest dehumanization of
republicans so it's it's not
it's not even like it was the
conservative democrats the most woke
ones were the ones
most likely to dehumanize their
opponents this study
is called meta dehumanization erodes
democratic norms during the 2020
presidential election they could
probably use
a better headline editor there kind of a
weak title
this would surprise democrats if they
were to read the study they won't
and this will not surprise republicans
who are on the brunt
of the dehumanization of the left
a political strategist on msnbc by the
way just for those of you who
are not in the cable news business who
are not in the political media
when you see someone come on television
that says political strategist
that is a synonym for unemployed
if they have a job it will say what
their job is if they don't it's a
political
strategist have you uh that's not that's
not a real job so this this woman
susan del percho goes on to
msnbc and
building upon this idea that democrats
are dehumanizing republicans she said
it's very clear right now
the gop needs to burn to the ground
i've been looking for a new word for
trumpism because i hate it because i
think it goes deeper than just donald
trump within the republican party
and i keep coming back to the same name
it's neo-fascism
it needs to burn down it literally needs
to be demolished before you can go in
and build it up again and you know the
people who actually say
why you know please stay republican are
democrats
who like to say let's argue back tax
policy because they know you need a
strong
republican party right now it's not
strong but it needs
it really does need to to be burned down
to the ground
so it can come back up but that also
means there has to be people willing
to keep their republican credentials to
be there when it's time to build it up
george orwell is often invoked in these
sorts of political discussions
and rightly so because he made some good
observations not just in 1984 but in an
essay called politics and english
language
in that essay orwell says that fascism
and he wrote this many many years ago
fascism no longer has any meaning
fascism now means no more than
something that i do not like something
that i do not desire
right this woman i suspect could not
define fascism
you know they tell us that we can't
define critical race theory yes we can
critical race theory
is an academic movement that developed
over the past 30 or 40 years
that says that america's defining
feature is its anti-black bigotry
and that this permeates every aspect of
the united states
including its its uh system of property
including its its
uh its economics and it derives from a
broader marxist tradition that's true
and you can read about it in my book
speechless and you can read about it in
other sources as well
what is fascism according to this woman
it's nothing george orwell writes in
this essay
that when people don't want to think not
even when they can't think but when they
don't want to think
they just you just open your mind up to
cliches and then the cliches fill your
head
and then they will do the thinking for
you and that's that's what has happened
this woman says
it's a neo-fascist party doesn't define
what that is
then she says you know
it needs to be burned to the ground and
we need a strong gop why why does this
woman i don't want a strong democratic
party why does this one want a strong
republican party it's just a thing that
she said it doesn't mean anything
and then she says we because right now
it's not strong well if it's not strong
what are you so worried about why does
it need to be burned to the ground
you're worried because it is strong this
is like when people including nancy
pelosi
complained to donald trump that the
border wall
was ineffective and inhumane
hold on which is it if it's ineffective
then it's not inhumane because it's not
bothering anybody
if it's inhumane then it's not
ineffective because it's actually doing
something
but it's just these words that don't
mean anything they just
fill the air it's so beyond any
political point that this woman thinks
that she's making
it's this shallowness this pathetic
rhetoric that just does it's just words
it's not even
it's just grunting it's like it's
somehow below the level
of speech and obviously very
dehumanizing
you'll notice not that republicans can't
get riled up but when we speak about
people on the left
we tend to be a little calmer because we
know where they're coming from we know
what their premises are we know how
they're going to get to a conclusion
it's too bad it's bad for the country we
want to stop it but we get it
with these people i mean goodness
gracious this
woman is about as shrill as it gets
because they don't understand they
actually don't understand where we're
coming from they don't get
why someone would vote for donald trump
or whoever the next nominee is going to
be or
or before trump it was romney was the
worst guy ever remember that then it was
mccain then it was bush and then
it's our democracy you see our democracy
demands that we have a strong republican
party
but not a but and now it's weak but it's
also too strong and it doesn't
doesn't make a lot of sense senator bob
casey democrat from pennsylvania
is using this phrase our democracy which
the claremont institute's angelo
cotavilla points out
whenever the left refers to our
democracy they're usually referring to
their oligarchy but he says our
democracy is at the point of no return
because republicans don't want to
federalize election law in the largest
power grab that
that we've seen maybe in our nation's
recent history through the the corrupt
politicians act
s1 and hr1 just for the moment at least
got shot down
and so because of that we need to
protect voting rights
we reach a point now with these supreme
court decisions
and with the uh the advent of all of
these what is it more than 400
voter suppression bills across the
country where
there is we're at a point of no return
we're either going to preserve our
democracy
and protect thereby protecting voting
rights or protecting voter rights to
preserve the democracy
or we're not we've come to i think a
point where
a democrats have to stand up and get
something done now i think we can do
that
because it's it's apparent to me that
republicans are just going to endorse
these voter suppression bills
and that is poor we should just be blunt
about this at its core
these voter suppression bills are about
white supremacy
and unfortunately it seems like the
republican party is becoming a one or
two
issue agenda party where they they seem
to be
only interested in uh stopping joe
biden's
programs especially on on these
caregiving issues
and and supporting voter suppression
bill
did anything he said there have
any meaning whatsoever it's just that
tyranny of cliches
the republican party is a party
obstruction white supremacy voting our
democracy
supremacy you know we can do it but
we're at the point of no return so we
gotta return wait i thought we were at
the point of no return
what are you this is why i wrote my book
people by the way thank you so much to
everyone who's made it
a uh number one bestseller very very
very cool guys appreciate i'm glad that
people are reading it i wish democrats
would read it
but especially at least as long as
republicans read it we have a chance
these words you've got to parse them
they just
they are just cudgels they are just
tools to smuggle in dumb ideas
through really really silly perversions
and distortions
of language do not let them do it they
are they are
you know there's there's the heavy hand
of the biden thugs going door to door
to try to jab your kids but there is the
more insidious
and frankly more effective political
strategy
of entering in through the back door of
your mind with this kind of
ridiculous rhetoric parse all these
words
voting rights white supremacy our
democracy this figure out what it really
means
i think it's going to i think it's going
to collapse before your very eyes and
then when we figure out what they're
really saying
and more importantly when we figure out
what we want to say then perhaps we can
push back beyond the point of no return
i'm michael noel's the michael nola show
i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boary our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadofsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
wall show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you your
family our country not just politics but
culture faith current events
all the fundamentals if they matter to
you come check out the show